hello everyone and what is hopefully the
first of many such ask me anything and
I'll perhaps answer anything that is
submitted to me via a variety a panoply
of different options we have available
to us in this digital age you can leave
me comments when I post a call for
questions to be asked on my YouTube
channel Community page that's Dr Brian
Keating you can send me an email in my
email list Brian keating.com list and I
can join my patreon ask questions there
by Dr Brian Keating
and on my website Brian keating.com
podcast you can leave a voice message
there's a tool there a widget called
speak pipe but will take about 20 30
questions from around these different
places oh Twitter is another place Dr
Brian Keating on Twitter where you can
solicit my input on your most burning
existential question and I'll try to do
this every so often this one's actually
a 60 000 subscriber celebration took me
so long to record it I actually am
honored to say we are now over uh
seventy thousand seventy one thousand
subscribers on YouTube please do
subscribe there you can ask me questions
interact with these brilliantbrainiacs
14 Nobel Prize winners four astronauts
three billionaires two Pulitzer Prize
winners and many many cool conversations
coming up in their future we just had in
episodes with Sean Carroll and Sabina
hassenfelder and some solo episodes
where I do conversations about deep
topics and experimental physics and
that's sort of becoming my Niche is to
really steal the Thunder in some way
from my brilliant theoretical colleagues
like Neil deGrasse Tyson or Sabina
hassenfelder and do what they can't you
know exploit my unfair Advantage which
is to do experiments in the laboratory
and talk about experiments as an
experimental physicist that's my
training and we'll explore the universe
of experimental physics on this channel
more and more with solo episodes and I
call those 10 minute thesis uh projects
and I'm really delighted to be sharing
those with you we have one coming up
soon about the most expensive water ever
made ever available to me at least in
the universe don't want to miss that so
do subscribe to the channel those
explainer videos are only available on
YouTube there's just no point in posting
the audio only but um but I hope you'll
do both subscribe to the podcast and to
the audio Channel and all my other feeds
and sometimes I like to reward Folks by
sending you free copies of my various
books I've written three or produced
three uh losing the Nobel Prize into the
impossible and also Galileo's dialogue
so sometimes I'll give those away other
people's books will give them away my
friend will Kinney past guest on the
show I'm giving his sign book Away uh an
Infinity of Worlds so you can find out
all of that all that information on my
website I'd love to give back I love to
teach
and I love to do experiments into Tinker
so let's begin with Twitter so as I said
um Dr Brian Keating on Twitter this
comes from a friend Jay Yao the slash
engineer he's a super producer too in
addition to Stuart volcano he works for
the James all toucher podcast and the
entire empresario that is uh James all
toucher what Jay is asking my super
producer buddy who was a guest about a
year and a half ago he asks is there
life out there in the universe other
than on Earth
what would it look like well they look
like me all right Jay I hate to break it
to you maybe I I don't you're handsome
man we've had uh shared meals together
delicious Chinese meals in the Upper
West Side they uh won't look like you
most likely and that's a good thing you
know UPS your dating uh probability well
first of all we have no real evidence we
have no evidence for life outside the
earth I often hear there's an abundant
probability just based on discoveries
from all sorts of disparate scientific
directions including the fact that the
Kepler satellite has demonstrated the
existence of thousands of planets around
other stars the James Webb Space
Telescope not only just recently
recorded the signature of an exoplanet
but also the fact that it had carbon
dioxide in its atmosphere the byproduct
of our respiration but none of that is
is evidence of life that's the evidence
of potential life and it's it's sort of
like saying you know if I look out here
in San Diego and I see the desert there
is a possibility of life life there are
certainly life forms that live out there
but in any particular location in the
desert there have to be an incredible
number of competing variables that have
to all conspire to be in place in order
for life you know a lizard a gecko
whatever there has to be just the right
properties for life to actually be there
it's not enough for life to potentially
be there and then the question is you
know will they look like you I guess you
know partially that has to do with
whether or not life is not only
ubiquitous but also technologically
advanced sentient conscious capable of
building societies we talked about this
in an episode called you know if Darwin
had a spaceship and that was with uh Dr
Eric kirschenbaum in the UK
and he makes the point in his book that
there's a tremendous number of things
that we would expect to find in his book
a zoologist Guide to the Galaxy
including if life does exist that there
would be a tremendous amount of culture
and civilization required to support and
Advance life form capable of
communicating its existence to us or
even visiting us or you know producing
some sort of technology that we could
see so that is is also a very high
hurdle to pass we have a just think
about our space program and how many you
know thousands hundreds of thousands of
people conspire in a good way to make
that program a success and in that sense
that requires that they have a common
organization and the financial system
and they have a culture and they have
language and they have mathematics and
all sorts of things so that's a huge
number of hurdles and I'm barely
scratching the surface and that's once
life exists matures evolves and becomes
sentient technologically and is able to
do all sorts of cool things so short
answer is
very probably not they won't look like
you it might have certain features that
you have but first we have to get to the
point of whether or not life exists at
all and then whether or not that life
could be technologically advanced thank
you my friend for the question moving on
reader
312. what is your most recommended book
based around physics and Engineering for
a student that is going to University
next year well you're in luck because uh
just recently I did an episode with Sean
Carroll Sean Carroll has a series of
books the first of which just came out
in September called the biggest ideas in
the universe and the first one is about
space time and motion which would be
likely your topics that you would have
to take in an introductory first year
physics class I know that's certainly
what we do here at UC San Diego where I
am a professor
and uh it covers a great deal of things
including the mathematical background
including calculus and some aspects of
of things like Symmetry and and other
properties that are incredible to know
about and then it culminates with some
really delicious red meat or white tofu
uh including things like black holes and
space-time diagrams that's incredibly
satisfying book there are other books
Lenny suskin has a series of books
called the theoretical minimum those are
more advanced I would say and uh sir
Roger Penrose has some books the road to
reality these are more kind of synoptic
overviews of all the physics from the
laptop of Masters like Lenny and Sir
Roger both pass guests on the podcast
and we you know have this notion that
you can kind of pick up as much as you
need to know during the school year but
actually it's much better I always tell
my students you should really never have
down time I mean I command them you know
I don't command them but I recommend
that they only work six days a week that
they never ever work seven days a week
based on kind of eyes that I have to uh
to give yourself a weekly Sabbath and to
relax and enjoy and not always be
focused on work because if you are
you're kind of beholden to your job or
in this case being a student and I think
that that's not entirely the best way to
approach life but that being said the
corollary to that is that six days a
week you should be thinking about your
job or your work or your avocation in
this case and that'll be physics so not
only reading the stuff that is required
reading but going Beyond it and that
will really tell you if you have kind of
the desire and passion to continue
through the really hard times you know
which you will encounter many times as
an undergraduate and maybe eventually as
a graduate student for me it was reading
books by Isaac Asimov science books not
science fiction ironically ironically I
say because I'm the associate director
of the Arthur C Clarke Center for human
imagination here at UC San Diego but I
was gravitated towards his science heavy
books rather than science fiction same
with Arthur C Clarke but I would read
biographies of Feynman and of Einstein
and
the great scientist and Carl Sagan all
sorts of my heroes and then eventually
Galileo who is still sort of in my life
and he's on my desk over here and you
can learn a lot from the struggles and
you can actually get into people's
personalities by reading a lot of
history of the field books by Tim
Ferriss the astronomer not the um you
know kind of body hacker uh podcaster
extraordinaire uh so Tim Ferriss wrote
many books coming of age in the Milky
Way it was a great one the history of of
science so read on the non-technical
kind of Popular Science front in
addition to you know losing the Nobel
Prize and into the impossible you should
read some some books that are technical
like either Sean's book or Lenny's book
or even sir Roger but but I really do
recommend Sean's book his new book uh
and in fact you know although I had
recommended in the past as Weinstein um
a friend of mine and Son of a friend of
the podcast Eric Weinstein I did assign
him so to speak a series of books
including Lenny suskins to get up to a
level that he far exceeded my
expectations of Nazis actually doing
original research soon after kind of
just devouring that series of books by
Professor Lenny suskin so it may happen
to you but don't feel bad if it doesn't
start off at your own pace but again the
most important advice is to keep the
Curiosity up I always say passion is
like a spark but the real feel is your
is your curiosity because that'll keep
you coming back for more rather than
just being inspired the very first time
to pick up a book and oh maybe I could
be like Feynman and then we found out
most of us can't be like a fireman
Prometheus warp X
on Twitter again these are coming from
Twitter find me on Twitter at Dr Brian
Keaton what happens to space-time near
an ultra intense ion ring as a musically
accelerating towards C the speed of
light while compressed towards zero
radius I have no idea I am sorry
Prometheus great name great question
presumably I think that this is take me
so far beyond into a second PhD to learn
about what is an ultra intense ion ring
how do you as mutually accelerate it
towards the speed of light and
compressing it to zero radius that would
be a cool thing but I have no idea what
would happen question number five I
think Bob kerbo on Twitter can you
explain why universe expanding at Super
luminal velocities would leave an
imprint like the polarization of the
cosmic microwave background radiation
can you describe the measurement to
measure the polarization well in fact I
can Bob in fact that's what I've
dedicated my life to uh the past 20
years or so all in pursuit of this which
I borrowed from sarandra when he was
here described in losing the Nobel Prize
over here but I'm not one of those
authors who says you know if you want to
know more buy my book
I always hate that I also hate when we
go on a podcast and they're like oh can
you explain your book and enough detail
and adapt that my listeners of this
podcast don't need to buy it no I won't
do that now I didn't write it to make
money but I did write it to convey a
message that needs to be revealed in
accordance with the kind of proper
background and the setting and the
characters I hope I've done that in my
books and I'll continue to improve I
hope so what is polarization first of
all polarization is the result of the
interaction between light and matter and
what happens when light interacts with
matter then determines its subsequent
polarization state so light generally
can be unpolarized or polarized when
it's unpolarized like light from the sun
it has no preferential orientation of
the transverse waves that we call
electromagnetic radiation these are
waves that oscillate up and down
their direction or plane of oscillation
of the electromagnetic field is what we
call the polarization so when light then
interacts with a material a medium it
could be a metal it could be an
insulator a dielectric it could be any
sort of material you like several
different things can happen some of the
light's intensity can be absorbed some
of the light's intensity can be
reflected and some of the reflected or
transmitted or absorbed radiation can
have a net polarization state accorded
to it meaning that you can have a
suppression of one of the axes of
polarization leaving the reflected light
to have a net polarization transverse to
it and that and that's what the basis of
a polarized sunglasses are so I've got
my cheap homemade polarized sunglasses
and what they do is they suppress one
axis of polarization they transmit one
and they block the other one so 50 of
light gets through and these are
sometimes used to suppress glare and you
can see it's sort of suppressing glare
but when I put two of them together as
I'm doing on YouTube sorry do subscribe
if you want to see it you rotate these
at right angles to each other they'll
completely absorb say the light or
they'll completely transmit it with a 50
suppression of the intensity because it
is absorbing and transmitting only one
polarization where does all this have to
do with polarization of CMB well Bob's
asking about the superluminal expansion
that's referring to inflation so
inflation is the hypothesized early
evolutionary phase of the universe that
kicked off The Big Bang that we know and
love today so it's not part of the
original Big Bang it is a later
explanation to explain some of the
lacunae the gaps in our understanding of
the Big Bang including how did it start
expanding in the first place it should
have contracted maybe to nothing and we
shouldn't even be here to ask questions
about its existence so it's a theory
first put forth by Alan Guth in the 1907
late 1970s early 1980s that were still
trying to really prove and it's a
question of you know can you actually
prove something in physics well the
closest that we we can have is have a
tremendous amount of circumstantial
evidence that would not prove inflation
but would rule out the alternative
hypotheses those alternative hypotheses
include sir Roger penrose's conformal
cyclic cosmology and an Aegis and Paul
steinhardt's bouncing cyclic models and
there are others string gas cosmology
those would be falsified in a certain
sense because the presence of
inflationary perturbations to the
space-time metric would cause waves of
gravity gravitational waves that would
then propagate through the universe
eventually causing a unique pattern of
polarization of the heat that we call
the cosmic microwave background
radiation and that's what the bicep
experiment was intended to do the South
Pole and that's what we're trying to do
with the Simon's observatory in Chile
and I have a lot of content about both
of those and I'll continue to do so not
the least of which because I think it's
the most fascinating thing I can do as a
scientist so I hope you'll check those
out and not hesitate from ask asking
more questions in the future thanks Bob
back on Twitter we have Ryan Hogan he's
asking will there still be a debate if
there's a hard problem of Consciousness
in 100 years if no who won what happened
well I don't have my crystal ball I do
have a crystal ball I keep it at home
though but I I don't know this is a very
good question of course the hard problem
of Consciousness is term coined by past
guest uh David Chalmers and that is
whether or not one can actually explain
the phenomenon of qualia or phenomenal
experiences and experiences of
um what type of maybe sensory
experiences and others this is a hard
problem between the physical phenomena
brain function and actual physical
function in the outside world and
whether or not other things entities
could have Consciousness as well we
talked about it it's remaining a hard
problem as far you know predicting
whether or not it will be answered it
will be solved I just don't know it's
it's a little bit beyond my potential
comprehension and I do feel like perhaps
we're in the phase of of Consciousness
studies that you know medicine was in
when it studied you know phrenology and
leeches and bloodletting and so forth so
I don't know I don't think anybody could
say for sure if it'll be solved because
I don't think it's something that can be
solved via mere application of thought
or computing power Etc although some
things might give us insight into the
hard problem you know simulated minds
and things that pass the Turing test or
as Sean Carroll called it the Keating
test whether or not a artificial general
intelligence would commit suicide in our
interview together
uh so Ryan don't know I think it's
incredibly interesting I think you know
philosophers have come up with all sorts
of ideas from you know pan psychism to
orc or gravity plays a role in
Consciousness it's an exciting field I I
think I love to learn about it not the
kind of field that I would get into just
because I like to actually be able to
build things and Tinker around and and
make progress on a human time skill
Etc don't know do care and uh appreciate
the question
next Twitter question comes from
unknowable Sky what a beautiful name is
it true that the new dark matter-less
galaxy would represent a significant
evidence against Mond if it is true
how contentious is this new discovery in
the astrophysics physics Community can
it be proven true thank you unknowable
sky so uh you're referring perhaps to
the video I did called this galaxy has
no dark matter and that we explored this
galaxy found by Professor Peter van
dalkem at Yale which suggests that there
is a Galaxy who is being orbited by
globular clusters which I describe in
the video and those globular clusters
are orbiting around the Galaxy which is
referred to by some huge long series of
characters AE shaw-12 as 22. no it has
another name we call it 1052 I think in
the video and these Globs balls of stars
are orbiting around the Galaxy and that
Galaxy just by its luminous matter alone
just counting up how many stars are in
it what it shows it doesn't require any
matter other than what's luminous to
control and cause the gravitational
motion of the globular clusters that
kind of orbit it like planets around our
sun or or any other gravitational
phenomena it doesn't require any dark
matter that is a challenge for mod and I
did talk to Mordecai Milgram about that
in our conversation linked up here which
is called No Dark Matter unfortunately I
do apologize that video had really
terrible audio on Matthew's side I'm
going to try to send him a microphone or
maybe go visit him in Israel next year
when I go back for my bar mitzvah
anniversary more details to follow maybe
we'll plan a trip there into the
impossible getaway but the response that
he has had is that it it doesn't there
are certain kind of loopholes I think it
would be one way to describe in the mon
Theory which don't require that all
galaxies if they're independent in other
words if they're not embedded in some
larger cluster of galaxies or some dark
matter Halo that they could be accounted
for within them on Paradigm you know
whether or not that remains true based
on say the more detailed studies that
will come out I think they could
spell trouble Vermont if say the web
telescope doesn't need the globular
clusters which are farther away from the
Dark Matter core and may or may not be
the best tracers of the gravitational
potential field of the Galaxy the web
telescope will be able to zoom in and
see the individual Stars orbiting inside
of the Galaxy and that will be a Keener
and more crisp test of the actual amount
of luminous matter in that Galaxy
because that's actually in the plane and
that's what mon really talks and mon
doesn't really have as much to say in my
understanding of it about the globular
clusters and things outside the core
radius of the inner gravitational
potential field what mon can do very
well is account for the rotation curves
of galaxies and we've talked about that
many times I'm sitting in the office of
Jeff Burbage and his late great wife
Margaret and they used to take images
and here's one of them a plate from
Mount Wilson I think it's older than me
these images were then used to take
Spectra here's a spectrum of a galaxy
that Margaret took you can barely see
these are on photographic glass plates
so cool it's a piece of History right
here and they then were collaborating
and teaching a young beer Reuben when
she visited right here at UC San Diego
back in the 60s and they kind of
inspired her to take up this rotation
curve business and galaxies and then she
showed that Galaxies have very flat
rotation curves and there was already
evidence from zwicki and others that
dark matter was something to be taken
seriously so that will be the Crispus
test that could spell
but stay tuned for that hopefully
that'll be coming soon
this one is right up my Canal no it's
it's actually not up my alley at all
it's from James Aragon who asked could a
canal from the sea of Cortez to Laguna
Salada could that help reduce droughts
and lower temperatures in the Colorado
watershed
absolutely no idea I don't even know
this was even thought about we do have a
giant Salt Lake here called the Salton
Sea which is a manufactured you know
man-made lake but that uh was really
meant to divert water from the Colorado
River cause a lot of tension uh it's
horribly polluted although it's getting
cleaned up it's kind of a cool area of
Southern California to visit in the
winter don't go there in the summer
you'll die so I don't know that's a it's
a question for the
for another podcast but but I guess I
did say ask me anything okay now we're
going to YouTube
answering some questions and you can
answer ask me questions there on my
community tab which you can get to on a
phone or a computer but not on an iPad
for some reason that I don't understand
yet but maybe one of my YouTube engineer
friends will be able to uh to explain it
to me the first question comes from
Floyd Aldridge who's a member of the
channel thank you Floyd that means he
supports it financially at something
like five to ten dollars a month and
that really does help to cover some of
the many expenses I do operate at a loss
I don't like to take video ads on the
podcast I find them a little bit
disruptive sponsorships not saying I
always uh will have that position but
you know for now I don't like it um yeah
it's enough ads on YouTube as it is I
have YouTube premium which is gladly
funded by people like Floyd and the many
other many many dozens of members that
pay a little bit each month to support
the podcast you can also do that on
patreon I have a similar number you know
a couple dozen supporters over there and
you can also super follow me on Twitter
apparently now for about the same amount
get priority to the folks that are
asking questions from those different
venues Floyd asks I know light can't
escape a black hole but how fast would
something have to go to escape well
that's kind of the the point is that to
escape means that in the future you
won't be inside the black holes
so-called Event Horizon and what sir
Roger Penrose proved in the 1960s that
led to his Nobel Prize was that there's
no such thing as a path within the black
holes once you get within the black
holes Event Horizon that doesn't include
a future event where you encounter the
singularity in other words your world
line will start to converge no matter
how much speed you have and the more
speed you have the the kind of faster it
will take for you to get into the black
hole Singularity that's the kind of
frustrating thing the more you struggle
it's like the ultimate quicksand you'll
never be able to escape no matter how
fast you could go you know and I don't
know about you know tachyons and things
that are faster than the speed of light
I think those are pretty fanciful
there's no evidence for such things so
it's not possible unfortunately so stay
away from it uh you'll get um more than
just spaghettify
next comes from schweta vs could you
please tell us more about the three main
approaches to relativistic gravitation
Theory or your views on it thank you so
there are many different so-called
theories of everything that attempt to
unify the laws of quantum mechanics the
laws of nuclear physics the laws of
electromagnetism with the law of gravity
those go under the rubric theories of
everything and in theories of everything
one encounters very many interesting
phenomena such as the fact that we have
no incredibly small microscopic scale
behavior of quantum mechanics that is
compatible with gravitation in other
words we have Infinities we have
singularities that emerge when you get
to say this the core Singularity of a
black hole so the for that reason we
don't have really a current
understanding of how gravity can be
reconciled there are approaches and
sweat is talking about those those
sometimes include geometric theories
that attempt to buy bind together
various group structures in the same way
that we bound together the weak nuclear
force with the electromagnetic force and
so-called su2 across U1 symmetry those
are group theoretic manifestations and
those might be quite good as well they
might be the right approach of course
string theory is another approach to
unification of gravity with quantum
mechanics but you know my thought is
that we really don't have a good Grand
unified theory where you unify together
the strong force with the weak force and
the electromagnetic force there is no
such current present theory that is
really accepted for that and it's not
for lack of trying so I always joke
we're putting the toes finding The
Theory of Everything ahead of the gut so
that can always be a fraught prop
proposition and I feel like more flowers
should Bloom than are currently blooming
but there's no real telling right now in
fact string theory is kind of undergoing
in Dark Ages and anti-renaissance I
don't know how to describe it where
people are really pessimistic about it
that doesn't mean it's wrong uh you know
we don't appeal to Authority on this
podcast but we've talked a lot about it
and then of course my friend Eric
Weinstein's his Theory of Everything
called geometric Unity which is another
type of geometric approach
there's past guest scare elisi's
approach there's a completely different
type of approach by Stephen Weinberg
which involves these kind of graphs
these Game of Life type structures that
we've talked about on the show together
as well and maybe it's time for an
update with him I've done more on the
kind of geometric front with Eric and
Garrett and others maybe it's time for
an update on the computational
complexity side of things thank you
sweater
still on Twitter chanic says when will
you have Lex Friedman on your show
thanks for everything thank you chanek
well I'm hoping that Lex will be on my
show when I go back on his show so I
invited myself back on his show and he
enthusiastically accepted for round two
which he calls around two and I said you
know uh what I really want is to have
you on my show and people are demanding
it like chanic and many others so
hopefully that'll happen uh late this
year early next year whenever we are
schedules and stars align for a trip
back to Austin and Lex has really upped
my game since I was on his show the
first time we'll put a link to that over
here I was on his show it's got about
1.4 million views uh so far it's four
hours long so if everybody watches it
let's say half the people watch it all
the way to the end everybody watches it
halfway uh then you're talking about
three million hours of very fine uh
television but let's just say what's 3
million
um divided by 168 so that's how many
weeks worth so that's 17
000 18 000 weeks of somebody's time uh
has been watched on this how many days
is that let's do that really quickly uh
now we're talking 125
000 person days have spent watching me
and Lex jabber uh and get ready for a
longer we actually recorded for five
hours when I was on the show the first
time he had to trim it down I think it
came out great that's got thousands and
thousands of Thumbs Up and comments and
I try to read them every so often so uh
thanks for that question short answer is
I'm gonna bring my microphone and turn
the tables on him he's aware of it Lex
game on brother LV gamer cats beautiful
name Dark Matter Armand which one do you
think the universe picked that's a very
good question I've you know spent a lot
more time thinking about particulate
Dark Matter modern the form of particles
than Monde although you know mon has
certain attractive features and some
people like past guests on the show
Sabina hasenfelder and and Stefan
Alexander have models that are are quite
you know attractive they have a lot of
fascinating you know aspects to
recommend them I don't feel though that
uh that it's conclusively possible to
say whether or not it will be one or the
other in fact it could be both right it
could be that some aspects of bond do
obtain and some aspects of particulate
Dark Matter do obtain it could be some
you know phase transition in matter that
obtains an ordinary matter these are all
really fascinating things different
possibilities so I wouldn't say now I
have a lot of kind of familiarity that
could occur with my experience in the
cosmic microwave background experimental
field where we're actually doing you
know very similar types of low
temperature physics with detectors and
readout and data acquisition and data
analysis techniques these are you know
some of the most fascinating things I
think that one can study so you know
from my perspective I think the jury is
sort of still open on which of the two
would be right but um I'm fascinated to
find out more and I just happen to have
more from familiarity with the
particulate searches the direct
detection searches that doesn't mean
they're right but it is uh fascinating
to think that maybe there could be a
Confluence of these things and we could
have you know kind of the best of both
Dark Worlds okay I hope you continue to
submit questions to me and these future
ask me anythings this one was supposed
to come out months ago but uh due to my
sloth and so forth I've tarried long
enough and now it's time to put it out
there and answer your burning questions
floor Rebecca I think is how you
pronounce it says I have a bunch perhaps
you can choose which is at least
ridiculous
number one if we reverse the first
second of the Big Bang we see the
electromagnetic and weak nuclear force
merge if merge is the right word we say
they separated but it separate the right
word yes in some ways they become
different manifestations different
incarnations just like uh solid liquid
and gas phases or different phases of
water there's one underlying material
water and it changes its phase and it's
and Its Behavior as it is cooled or
warmed in this case going backwards in
time so yes I think that's the right
word separation you have phase
separation when it comes to things like
water liquid and gas and you have phase
transitions as the Universe goes from
being perhaps a single Force described
as described by a single Force namely
The Theory of Everything gravity plus
the strong and weak nuclear forces and
the electromagnetic force and then as it
cools down as the universe expands and
cools those forces fracture off and take
on unique identities that don't allow
them really to be perceived as a single
entity anymore so going backwards it's
sort of a form of unification going
forward it's a form of Separation so yes
I think that's fine okay Jimmy Jazzy
says what's your favorite thing in
mathematics is mathematics invented or
discovered
I think uh the answer to the second one
it's both we do discover things about
the universe but we also create things
about the universe now those are true
and they exist whether or not we
describe them or not but when you think
about the actual practical application
of mathematics say calculus calculus was
invented in a sense by two different
mathematicians leibnets and Newton and
it was invented for a particular purpose
and then it was discovered that it had
application to the physical world namely
that Newton's Laws could be very
accurately modeled by calculus so I
think it's both of course it's an
eternal question nobody really has the
right answer to but that's the way I
think about it Blake Lyon says now I'm
reading again for my YouTube Community
page Blake asks in what ways is it
accurate or inaccurate to think of
galaxies as a giant solar system as
giant solar systems with stars orbiting
massive core areas instead of planets
orbiting a star it's a very good model
in a lot of ways and in fact that model
is not terribly inapplicable to even an
atom borer received his Nobel Prize for
basically a planetary model of the
hydrogen atom and so it has a positive
descriptive power and therefore it's
useful it can allow one to calculate
many different properties in the case of
the solar system though it differs in
that 99.8 percent of the matter in the
solar system is contained in the sun our
galaxy has far far less contained in a
central point which is maybe arguably
Sagittarius A star the supermassive
black hole at the center of our galaxy
that is a physical point and it is true
of mathematically speaking the stars and
are orbiting around that point as the
scent at the center of the Galaxy but
it's not orbiting because of the gravity
of the black hole that black hole is
beautiful
Mass comparison and a mass comparison
with the total mass of the Galaxy which
has several hundred billion solar masses
as compared to 6 million or so solar
masses worth of mass in that black hole
so it's massive certainly and the
objects that orbit around it do behave
and they have certain properties that
are Newtonian but to accurately describe
them you need to use general relativity
the closer they get to the black hole so
close in the approximation of calling it
a solar system is perhaps less precise
but not really less accurate we need to
describe the orbit of the innermost
planet in our solar system using general
relativity and that's Mercury which led
Einstein to come up with the theory of
general relativity so it's a very useful
model it's of course the Galaxy is not a
perfect plane neither is the solar
system nor is it true that that all the
matter in the solar system nor all the
matter in the galaxy is visible matter
that can emit light on its own accord
and be detectable so yeah it's it's
useful of course it's they're they're
quite different uh in a detailed level
Thank You Blake another one taking me
far far out of my comfort zone into the
impossible Sean Mitchell asks what do
you think of the postulation that the
universe is a fractal pattern hologram
made tangible by interacting
electromagnetic fields and that the only
two things that really exist are light
in many of all forms and Consciousness I
I have no thoughts on this I've never
heard such an expression fractal pattern
hologram don't really know what that is
and uh tangible by electromagnetic
fields that really exist um I'm not sure
what that means we know that matter
exists we know that that light is just
one form of energy in our universe
Consciousness see above we don't really
have a model for how Consciousness
emerges or if it really emerges some say
it's an illusion some like past guest on
the show Nick Bostrom claim we are
living in a simulation at a certain
level so no we do have another question
about fractals from schweta vs what
exactly is fractal science and why do we
see fractal patterns all over nature in
the universe so it is true we have
fractal behavior on the largest scales
in the universe the distribution of
large-scale structure in the universe
traces a fractal-like pattern with
fractal Dimension so what does a fractal
means fractional Dimension it is
something that doesn't have a neat
integer Dimension like a line or point
or a even a sphere or cube
Etc so it has an in between Dimension
and we'll put up some illustrations of
various fractals the mandelbrot set is
one the lorenza tractor is another what
is the dimension of that what is the
dimension of the coastline of California
it's not a line because if you zoom in
farther and farther you get a longer and
longer Coastline that doesn't happen for
an ordinary line and so these are famous
problems fractals manifest themselves in
the behavior of certain functions that
describe complex phenomena not
complicated phenomena like building a
microwave telescope it's not it's not
complex in that it has sensitivity to
initial conditions and so forth it
doesn't you start off you have the
materials you build it and it works it's
hard as hell take it for me and my
students and and colleagues are the best
in the known universe at doing these
things but it's not complex you'll get
the same result every time in principle
if you follow the same instructions just
like solving a puzzle but puzzles can be
really complicated but a fractal depends
very sensitively on where you start and
of course the famous Butterfly Effect
coined by James Glick who maybe I'll
have on the show someday the butterfly
effect being the thought being that tiny
perturbation of a butterfly in Australia
would flapping its wings would later
cause a tornado in Texas we don't have
such fine scale modeling that actually
proves that such things occur and that
my conversation with Tim Palmer who's
called recipient of the Nobel Prize
peace prize for his work on climate
change he and I discussed this very
effect and in fact it's The Core theme
of his book and and more interesting
maybe even than all that as interesting
as that is how do we understand the
transition from the classical World
which has things like chaos and weather
and fractals and so forth to the quantum
realm where we don't have like fractal
Behavior per se but we have entanglement
and that was really fascinating I refer
you to that conversation hopefully it'll
be out um uh very soon and uh you know
enjoy that that's based on his new book
called The Primacy of Doubt a James
russianeski or shine asking
asks what is needed for people to move
to Proxima Centauri system so are these
some like annoying neighbors James I
mean you gotta feel me who are the
people we're talking about who do we
want to get rid of here
um gotta gotta be careful about that
um so for people to go to Proxima
Century would be quite a ways Proxima
centuries the nearest star system to the
Earth it even has an exoplanet that's
orbiting around called Proxima Centauri
B that could even be you know similar in
some ways to the Earth so to move there
would require that we get there so
voyagers moving really fast best thing
ever made by humans so it would take uh
26
000 times the time that light would take
to get the process into rep so you're
talking about hundred thousand plus
years to get there I don't think people
can ever get there now if you're
traveling at the speed of light then of
course time gets dilated and you don't
experience that time but if we're just
talking about what would it take now it
would take a hundred thousand years so
don't get your hopes up I don't think
Bezos are mask
either one of them is really too keen on
you know selling uh trips to that deep
in outer space although Richard Branson
I don't know that guy's kind of crazy
he's he's thinking that he can make a
huge business out of sub-orbital space
flight which we achieved back in you
know back in the 1960s and he wants to
sell rides for you know quarter million
a pop it's pretty expensive way to brag
to your friends right at a cocktail
party
so I don't think it's in the cards uh
let's work on Mars first maybe that'll
be more practical if such a thing could
even be called practical Joseph Rapp
asks what is the evidence for and
against a Multiverse well there's no
evidence for it
um uh really there's no data that's
suggested there's a possibility one
could obtain data for it if one were to
observe sort of patterns of interaction
of a cosmic microwave background that
would be reflective of an encounter with
another universe and that the encounter
point this globe over here imagine it
crashing together with another Globe
like it well where they intersect those
two regions of the two different
disparate universes in the Multiverse
which share properties and so therefore
you could expect to see the impact
surface between those and maybe the
manifestation of that would be a circle
if you take two spheres and smush them
together the border of the boundary
where they overlap is a circle so people
have proposed Lathan Boyle and others I
did video about this on the solo episode
side of things 10 minute thesis side of
things and you can find that evidence
you know for a Multiverse so we haven't
seen it short answer spoiler alert
against a Multiverse also hard to really
say that you can't have a Multiverse uh
first of all there are many different
you know incarnations of the Multiverse
the you know simplest one could just be
to say
that their regions of space-time
inaccessible to us
at the most rapid possible speed meaning
that we can't interact or communicate
with regions of our own Universe because
they lie outside of our causal Horizon
that's the simplest level and then it
could go all the way up to different
every mathematical structure exists in a
universe of its own like Max tegmark has
talked about or it could be that there's
different universes in in terms of their
different physical properties the
different laws of physics different
physical constants different speeds of
light gravitational forces
electromagnetic charges strength so we
just don't know but I think it's
fascinating to contemplate them one
thing's for sure if we do discover that
inflation took place there'd be a lot
more evidence for it in this book of
course which I'm going to give away on
my website signed by the author will
Kinney an Infinity of Worlds is just
about that well on uh so here you get
the actual signed copy uh when you
subscribe to my mailing list you go to
my website you'll find giveaways Galore
so enter those and you'll be entered to
win this book it's really hard for me to
ship these things around the planet so I
really only can ship to my friends in
the United States of America but I'm
planning to go to Europe next year I've
been invited to go there for various
events so maybe I'll drop some of them
post I'll post them when I go there to
England Italy I'll keep you guys abreast
of that if you subscribe to my mailing
list which I'll put the link here right
below and that's very simple that's just
uh Brian keating.com list and you may be
entered to win uh some upcoming space
swag could be a meteorite could be a
Nobel Prize
but I didn't have to uh steal another
one from another Laureate friend
Shredder vs ask again with regard to
baryon symmetry when the universe was
created and the principles of symmetry
there should exist equal amounts of
matter antimatter both should annihilate
each other on ideally there'd be nothing
we now know there's a violation of that
symmetry my question what is the reason
matter is preferred over antimatter
another phenomenal question Sweda we
don't know the universe has a tiny
broken Symmetry and without it we
wouldn't be here to ask the question as
to why there is a tiny asymmetry at the
part per billion level
in other words for every 1 billion and
one protons in the early Universe there
were 1 billion antiprotons and those
folks annihilated with each other and
what was left over were two billion
photons and the single proton of single
particle of matter and we don't know we
know that ratio exquisitely well from
observation of the CMB and other
corroborating pieces of evidence from
big bang nucleosynthesis but we don't
know why that is there are many
different people working on this and
there are certain conditions that need
to be in place in order for the Symmetry
to be violated but I always say you know
we talk a lot about Symmetry and how
important symmetry is I mean neither
proved a very famous theory that relates
symmetric operations with conserved
quantities like energy angular momentum
linear momentum but we don't know why
they have applicability but also it's
when the symmetries get broken that
things that are interesting occur the
Higgs boson Mass mechanism is only
possible because of a broken symmetry in
the Aquatic and potential of the Higgs
boson so we don't really know why that
is but lucky that it is or else we
couldn't be here to ask and hopefully
answer partially some questions okay
I'll go back to Twitter with my friend
Tyler Goldstein
he says if you could change something to
improve the education accreditation
system of Academia what would you change
uh it's a very good question I think
about this a lot uh are we essentially
in a Hunger Games in Academia have we
effectively closed the the door to
really the level of success that was you
know present and possible just a few
decades ago when I was becoming a
professor the odds are so much harder
now to get a faculty job and I used to
compare it to say getting into the NBA
or let's say the Major League Baseball
here in America we have this farm system
where there's single a double a triple A
there's also a new one that they added
Like A Plus or something I don't know
anyway let's say there's three levels
single a double a triple A and then
there's the major leagues if you're
really good right so I kind of made the
analogy between you know undergraduate
graduate school postdoc and then faculty
I'm not comparing uh any of those so I'm
just saying in terms of the statistics
and the odds to get from levels to level
levels it's much harder I think to get
from say undergraduate to graduate
school than it is to get from single a
baseball to double A baseball and it's
certainly extremely hard to go from AAA
baseball which in this analogy we'd say
being a postdoctoral research scientist
into becoming a faculty member that's
that's really hard that'll be major
leagues in fact it's so hard that every
single slot we have for a professorship
here and this is true across all the
comparable R1 Top tier universities like
mine and even some of the you know not
R1 schools but even further down the
line teaching colleges or whatever that
don't do research
and the odds are 400 to 1 which is
harder than to get into in other words
you have a higher probability of going
from AAA to the major league than you do
from going to be a postdoc to being a
faculty member and then getting a grant
and then getting tenured and then
winning a Nobel Prize who knows those go
down exponentially but the difference is
that it is hard to become a postdoc but
there's many many more jobs you know one
of the problems is there's far more jobs
to be in the AAA system analogy than to
be in the you know at Major League
Baseball so we have this surplus of of
incredibly brilliant people that have
good jobs that have good Awards and
honors but they're not permanent the
academic environment does not confer a
permanent position to a post-doctoral
scientist it's kind of the stepping
stone where you learn how to build out
your own lab you build it up you study
under another professor under their
mentorship and then you become a mentor
to your own postdocs if you get a
faculty job but it's incredibly hard and
it's one of the things I don't know how
to address it could be that we have too
many post-docs and it could be people in
The Faculty realm need to stop you know
kind of
um you know encouraging so many postdocs
and then the question is well if you
don't have as many postdocs then you
shouldn't have as many graduate students
so maybe we should have fellowships and
encouraging them and I think the answer
is that we need more faculty
I'm not saying this self-interested I'm
already tenured I have an honorary chair
professorship it's not self-interested
for me
we have this enormous institution with
an enormous brand and all these colleges
that I work with the best schools in the
universe and literally I work with
people very close colleagues on every
one of the six continents where there
are universities and I'm trying to start
one in Antarctica next time I go down
I'll do it so why don't we have more
professors well we don't have uh room
for students we've kept a student to
faculty ratio for decades it hasn't
grown it hasn't kept up of inflation the
number of slots has gone down I remember
getting into Brown University and and
being overjoyed and thinking that was
great now it's basically impossible to
get into breath I mean you have to be
you know so incredibly off the charts
with with extracurriculars forget about
you know grades in some cases the grades
are less relevant and it's sort of
become a purview of alumni and maybe
donors in some cases and you know that's
less common in a state school like UC
San Diego but we have incredibly hard
and competitive emission rates the
across the UC it's only only like 12
percent you know when I was a kid
applying to college
Harvard was like eight percent nine
percent now it's three or four percent
so it's gotten incredibly out of control
very hard to get in and places like MIT
or you know Harvard can brag that they
they turn away you know nine harvards a
year in other words there's there's kids
good enough to go to Harvard or UC San
Diego and we turn them away and in
California at least we we do have a
mission to serve in the public school
system to serve a certain number of
in-state students which the other
schools don't have and so for that
reason we're more diverse we have more
kind of socioeconomic diversity uh
because we can't you know really
discriminate against people based on
income or ability to pay it's really you
know are they good enough do they meet
the prerequisites or not so it's been uh
it's been frustrating so short answer
increase the number of slots now the
tuition is increased faster than the
rate of inflation or the rate of growth
of the universities we've grown at two
percent uh or four percent maybe in
California across the board for how many
undergrounds we admit inflation that's
the prices have doubled in 20 years and
the tuition and fees and so forth and I
know that's true at private schools
maybe even more so and the faculty
really haven't changed that much so the
faculty are kind of growing below the
rate of students so in other words we
could solve a lot of things if we if we
you know had more students then we could
justify more faculty which would then
justify more post-docs which could then
or of us you know maintaining the level
of postdocs but increasing the percent
that become faculty from one quarter of
a percent to uh you know something more
manageable like two percent or something
it's not an easy problem to solve and
then you have to battle with well where
do you house these students and do they
need to be on campus and I think there's
a lot of room for things that could be
taught off campus that don't need a
physical campus to to do you know you
don't need a physical campus as much in
an English class as you do in a
laboratory science like physics or
engineering and so could have a hybrid
scenario where you know we we do some
teaching offline I've been doing you
know some Zoom still even though I'm
teaching in person again but anyway
long-winded way of saying we need to
grow faculty uh which will eventually
grow the number of Faculty just by
having more Supply and even just keeping
the manned the same
okay last question from Twitter for this
inaugural ask me anything comes to my
friend Martin Bauer professor in the
United Kingdom what is your prediction
he asked for the Simon's Observatory
measure of the Hubble constant I think
you know it's it's dangerous to predict
you know what you're going to see in an
experiment as you know Martin but I
would think that
um since Plank and wmap are in such good
agreement those are two other CMB
experiments spaceborne experiments act
in the South Pole telescope are also in
large agreement with the measurements of
Planck W map it would be you know just
from a Bayesian perspective I would
expect that we would measure something
on the Lower Side closer to those values
but we never know I'm more interested in
kind of you and other theorists and and
other experimentalists and observers
like myself how could we explain it I'm
always of the mind that we want to use
as little magic as possible despite the
opening line of the podcast but read by
Sir Arthur C Clarke that any
sufficiently advanced technology is
indistinguishable from Magic
I would love to have as little magic as
possible meaning that we don't have to
appeal to some strange new force field
or or you know dark unseen component I'm
actually you know most intellectually
kind of attracted to an explanation that
involves magnetic fields and primordial
magnetism I did a video about that
called Hubble crisis solved with magnets
a fascinating kind of conjecture of how
early magnetic field energy has just the
right properties to produce a very
rapidly expanding early universe that
then you know can decay in a certain
sense and so we could measure a higher
Hubble constant at later times with the
optical type experiments and a lower
Hubble constant at the Early times from
the CMB my friends have worked on that
and uh so yeah that video is there for
you to check out and see what you think
and give me feedback on that I guess I
should also check Instagram
can find me there guess what the moniker
would be a Dr Brian Keating on Instagram
being on Instagram I'm not as attracted
to it or Facebook as I am to the Twitter
or the YouTube Community page so that's
usually where you'll find these
solicitations for you to ask me anything
bonus comes from Andy Oates who's a very
good friend of the podcast I'm surprised
he didn't write me on YouTube but
instead wrote me on uh Instagram do you
think the American government is Right
period Then he says that UFOs are real
and we are being visited by people not
of this world well Andy I don't know if
that's what the US government is saying
I am a very big skeptic uh about UFOs
but I'm an optimistic skeptic in other
words I hope that I'm wrong I think
there are people that that don't want to
change their opinion that believe that
there are no such things that this is
all you know fiction figments of
imagination that these objects are you
know easily explained in other ways and
then there are people that you know
think that they're totally real and
guaranteed to be there and we should pay
very strict attention to them because
this could represent you know a threat
or you know something incredibly
interesting to to know about I'm again
I would like nothing better as any
scientist would to actually make contact
with another civilization because we'd
be able to get an actual maybe level
jump a level up to physics of the 25th
Century this would be amazing and any
scientist worth his or her salt should
kind of endeavor to be excited by that
subject that being said we have to ask
if the current level of evidence Rises
to the occasion and a lot of what I've
seen has to do with and I've talked to
many of the people involved with these
things CIA operatives to you know people
like Tom Delong Who's involved with uh
his own project who the Stars Academy
Mick West on the on the opposing side
who believes that everything can be
explained and and does a good job at you
know kind of providing evidence at least
against the interpretation that these
are extraterrestrial so I don't think
the US government has any position on it
I think it is of interest to people like
pilots and Military because if it's not
of this out of this world it could be a
threat to our national security although
I have to say given how badly we blew
kovid and even things like the Ukraine
Invasion we have these trillion dollar
three-letter agencies like the TSA and
the NSA and DARPA from I guess five
letters and all sorts of other agencies
and we failed to even diagnose you know
the problem with kovid was coming to our
shore and at some level represented a
huge threat to our security I knew about
it you know thanks to a dinner guest in
January of 2020 you know what China was
doing and you know building hospitals
and in eight days that can house or
imprison a thousand people
these are things that we should have
known about if I knew about them from
you know someone at a at a dinner on a
Friday night certainly we could have uh
gone into mass production of masks or
you know uh hand sanitizer all the
things that we ran out of toilet paper
um you know thinking back now it's it's
it's it's astonishing the fact that we
had some sort of a treatment of you know
vaccine or not depending on your
perspective but we've had these vaccines
for a while
uh maybe we could have had them earlier
and maybe they couldn't have been this
they wouldn't have been as politicized
and maybe wouldn't have had these
economic shocks that then caused us to
have to invest trillions more or spend
I'll say you know trillions of more
dollars so how do we not catch that if
the government is so good and so you
have to ask if they're suppressing
information how come they're so good at
doing that this conspiracy is so
effective it's suppressing knowledge of
actual alien beings but so ineffective
at dealing with the most basic functions
you know sort of keeping the lights on
keeping us safe that's the you know main
role of the government in my idea
okay I actually I can't resist answer my
friend Jeremy and goes by the name of
alien scientist big YouTube channel the
same name yes three questions I'm gonna
answer one of them which is what are
your opinions of the Galileo project
and Avi loves theories on Interstellar
objects so I have Avion multiple times
on the podcast at least three or four
times he's a friend I actually
volunteered for project Galileo to be on
their external advisory committee I did
that for about a year I didn't really do
much but to be honest with you but you
know having it having some level of
accountability I thought would be a good
thing and you know what avi's doing now
I think is pivoted away from you know
focusing no pun intended on this object
and more on other types of objects and
future objects that might be discovered
including this so-called I shouldn't say
so-called as a majority of this
Interstellar meteorite which is has been
confirmed which is he's going to lead an
expedition privately funded Expedition
you know it's good to be at Harvard and
he's gonna go down to go scuba diving in
Bali or wherever this object is now I
kind of gently chatted him back when he
and I chatted in January 2021 when his
book extraterrestrial came out about his
conviction that um really was real as an
extra terrestrial visitor an object a
technological relic of a distant
civilization not of our of our solar
system
and I said Avi if you really believed in
this and you did have access to the
billionaires that you do have access to
why don't we go and catch up in lasso
rather than sending tiny little
spacecraft as the project star shot that
he was involved with in co-leading to
Proxima Century B uh at best we have
some information from Proxima Centauri B
in 50 years whereas if we caught up you
know with the same type of cameras
caught up to a muamua and landed on it
and maybe captured it put little
thrusters on it did our best Bruce
Willis imitation you know that's in our
Solar backyard compared to a moon
compared to Proxima Centauri B
furthermore we'd get information back
you know more or less immediately
because it's still heliopause of the of
our solar system uh it was it was
traveling very fast but it's not fast as
the speed of light so that being said I
I wondered about his conviction at that
time he said to me well with the Via
Rubin telescope and other instruments
we'll be seeing you know five of these a
week or something once that comes on
online and you know I just had to think
well there's a lot of things that are
likely that never pan out you know in
physics there's a saying that you know
99 of three sigma detections are wrong
and you know they should have a
probability of being wrong of you know
point four percent or something like
that what if they don't what if what if
beer Reuben you know we're just unlucky
and these uh extraterrestrial garbage
barges they didn't send out a salvo of
them or we're not able to see the ones
that come as close as this one did it
was on my birthday about five years ago
in Hawaii when it was spotted so you
know he didn't seem to agree uh so he's
obviously moved on again no pun intended
from from amuamua and is on to other
things like this meteorite in uh that
fell to Earth maybe digging out I think
that's going to be uh maybe harder than
going to a muamu to dredge out a you
know a couple kilograms of meteorite in
an area of the South Pacific Ocean I
think that's going to be a challenge but
if anyone can do it it is Avi and for
now like I said I really enjoy it I hope
you guys enjoyed this first ever ask me
anything maybe we'll do it again when I
hit another round number of subscribers
please do subscribe uh to the YouTube
channel which is Dr Brian Keating
Twitter Dr Brian Keating Instagram Dr
Brian Keating can leave me a voice
message anytime at my podcast page which
is listed on the screen first I should
say sign up to my mailing list
briancade.com list that is listed for
now and let me type in my podcast
website where you can leave a speak pipe
a voice message I listen to every single
one of them can't promise I can answer
every single one as things ramp up I get
busy teaching this coming year got a
bunch of brilliant new graduate students
undergraduate students hiring a new
postdoc soon going down to Chile soon to
work on the Simon's Observatory that'll
be fun and traveling to Europe as I
mentioned next year maybe Israel so a
lot of fun stuff coming up we have
interviews with people like will
mccaskill who's written a wonderful book
about philanthropy in the future huge
number one bestseller around the world
our past catalog is unmatched with folks
like Sean Carroll and Sabina
hassenfelder Weinstein Jim Simons the
late great Freeman Dyson 14 Nobel Prize
winners and I love to do it and on my
YouTube channel exclusively I do videos
about explaining experimental science
that's where my unfair Advantage my
Niche is doing experiments analyzing
experiments thinking experimentally and
teaching you you know people always say
I'm not Einstein I don't want to be a
physicist well Einstein was an
experimentalist and even a good old
Albert made a lot of blunders as you
know he wasn't perfect but even if he
was you don't have to be him you can be
you can do stuff and anybody with an
interest in taking things apart and
solving puzzles can be an
experimentalist a tinkerer you were all
playful as a kid every single one even
new theorist so I want to explain how
these experiments work what the cool
aspects of them are how do we interface
and learn about experiments and use them
to learn and refine our knowledge about
theories as well and that's my mission
so I hope you'll join me join my various
uh lists and so forth and uh until next
time wishing you a magical rest of your
week
signing off Yours Truly Dr Brian Keating
[Music]